the kind of economic arrangements that
exist in our world today which are
dominated by cronies of those with state
power that's not the kind of economic
arrangement than anybody who believes in
freedom auto favor hi I'm Zach
Weissmuller with Reason TV we're here
with Gary Chartier
associate dean at La Sierra University
School of Business and editor of the
book markets not capitalism which he
co-edited with Charles W Johnson it's
available on Amazon Gary thanks for
joining us pleasure to be here Zak the
thing that probably a lot of
libertarians wonder about when they see
the title markets not capitalism
what's wrong with capitalism if by
capitalism you just mean absolutely free
markets we have no problem at all with
that but there are lots of other
meanings which are just as common if not
more common things like business
government partnership social dominance
by the owners of capital the my personal
favorite
whatever the economic system we have now
is I think that's that's when people
often seem to use a lot and we're pretty
uncomfortable with the economic system
we have now because it's riddled by
state secured privilege and we'd like to
get rid of that privilege there's words
in common usage now people say
corporatism or crony capitalism but you
actually say we need to go further than
that and disavow all capitalism yeah I
think it has a lot to do with the flavor
that that word has in the minds of some
people the history the word has and in
particular I'm going to keep saying this
association with whatever it is we have
now the kind of economic arrangements
that exist in our world today which are
dominated by folks who are cronies of
those with state power that's not the
kind of economic arrangement than
anybody who believes in freedom ought a
favor the first essay in your book talks
about the notion of freed markets why is
that the first essay in your book and it
could just explain the concept sure
William Gillis writes a great essay
talking about why freed is important why
is freed important because the markets
we have now aren't free they're
distorted by state secured privilege in
all kinds of different ways and to say
that we favor freed
markets or if you will liberated markets
is to emphasize that there's a task
ahead of us if we want freedom there's
something to be achieved it's not a
matter of celebrating what we have now
it's a matter of making something
dramatically different and exciting
happening talk a little bit about that
what is the difference in what a free
market would look like from what we have
now well let's take an obvious example
health care okay we have a healthcare
system which is regularly defended by
conservative pundits as largely free and
distorted a bit by government
intervention but the fact is it's
fundamentally distorted by government
intervention consider for instance the
range of licensing requirements on
health care professionals that limit who
can provide health care services the
constraints on what products can be sold
Hospital accreditation requirements
kinds of limits the drug patents create
and so forth so across the board the
healthcare market is miss shaped by
government intervention and what I worry
about is the people who talk as if what
we had was basically a freed market
assume it seems to me that let's say in
the context of health care all we'd have
to do is I don't know get rid of
Medicare and get rid of Obamacare and
then suddenly we'd have a free market in
health care and that's just ridiculous
in your intro you write markets laboring
under government and capitalism are
pervaded by persistent poverty
ecological destruction radical
inequalities of wealth and concentrated
power in the hands of corporations
bosses and landlords do you really think
every hierarchy or power structure would
be obliterated in a totally free market
I don't think every hierarchy would be
obliterated what I would say is most
people don't particularly like
functioning in hierarchical settings I
think a lot of us tolerate them because
they're useful in one way or another but
most people don't like them the more
competitive a market it seems to me the
more free market the more options people
have the more options people have I
think the more they're going to tend to
pursue alternatives that give them more
freedom more elbow room in the workplace
and the other institutional settings in
which they work does that mean you get
absolutely flat organizations probably
not but I think it means people have
more options and more opportunities to
choose opportunities for greater
participation
a lot of this seems to be a sort of
outreach to the left how do you convince
them that stronger stronger regulation
stronger government is not the answer if
we talk about outreach I mean this isn't
a kind of sham that is we really believe
the things we're saying here and we're
very happy to identify with the broad
history of the political left this isn't
the Kay it isn't some kind of subterfuge
that we're engaged in how would we go
about talking about that to people I
guess the most important thing to
emphasize is the actual history of the
growth of regulation businesses love
cartels they don't like competition big
business can manipulate the political
process to yield the regulations it
wants under the guise of protecting the
consumer and we think that's
consistently what happens how do we move
forward from here lots of us have
different strategies and I don't think
the book represents one coherent
argument about just the right attack to
take I have a lot of respect for people
who are involved in Agra strategies to
just try to try to tunnel under the
existing order and get out from under it
by operating below its radar I certainly
respect the people who want to try
seasteading and other options of that
kind to simply you know put competitive
alternatives out there that put pressure
therefore on the status quo to change
but one strategy that you seem to not be
as friendly to as a strategy such as
some sort of privatization efforts
what's wrong with trying to make the
government run more like a market I'm
all for radical privatization and the
book includes you know a couple of great
pieces by Murray Rothbard and Carl Hess
that talk about ways in which existing
government functions and government
collusive enterprises could be taken
over by the public and by the people who
work at them and I have no problem with
that at all but I think trying to make
the government run more efficiently
doesn't get at the root problem that the
government's funding is monopolistic
it's putting resources into things that
you or I might not have any great
interest in seeing funded at all knowing
for instance that prisons are run more
efficiently doesn't change the fact that
the prisons are there primarily to house
the victims of the drug war which I
don't want to see happening in the first
place everyone under 18 is forced to go
to
in education institution is it better to
have some sort of choice in the form of
you know milton friedman's voucher
program it's undoubtedly better to have
more options though I think that the
critics of vouchers who say you really
run the risk of just getting the state
involved in and managing even more
closely the recipients of the the
vouchers I think they have a real point
and I'd really prefer the approach of my
friend Sheldon Richman who wants to
argue strongly for abolishing the state
school system if there are one essay in
this book that you could recommend for
someone who might be from the
pro-capitalist right or pro-capitalist
libertarian what would you recommend
where do you recommend they start
Charles Johnson is the source of the
best stuff in the book I think and I say
that with apologies to all my other
friends who were involved Charles is
just such a brilliant synth assistant
analyst I'd say Charles's essay markets
freed from capitalism might be the
single best introduction to the position
that someone new to the conversation
might find in the book great gary
sardini thank you very much for joining
us today play your beer
four recent TV and zack wise moment
you